[Music]
[Music]
so we've got it good morning it's day
two in Taiwan we about to go to Joe Joe
fun up take it away
ah Becky is coming with us to Japan
Java but lots of fruits fruits I am
happy
[Music]
two different kinds are straight Kiran
klava
hello Becky good morning I like how
you're super quiet right with the Kappa
oh good good morning so in Taiwan we
have something called yo-yo car which is
the public transportation part and this
is how it looks like and if you put
money in here and you take the public
transportation it's actually cheaper
than just buying a
a single ticket so we try to use this
and we also use at 7-eleven which is
just recharger - there - it's pretty
convenient and so that's what I just did
for David yeah Bo yokai now what are we
doing now we're trying to get to Japan
and catch a train Express train that we
just purch it I guess trying to figure
out where it is
so I'm going to try my sandwich that I
got in the morning that I can't open
because somebody closes the Kryptonite
wait am I supposed to eat this all in
one go hmm
also it's just like one slice oh I
thought it was two separate sandwiches
oh boy
look at Taiwanese egg mcmuffin hmm you
can't this is super good
are all Cubans in Taiwan yellow
move yelling oh this is really good it's
not as tart as people we want supercard
even though you ate all of it this bag
was Phyllis position which is good all
your teachers purple
this one tastes like more like a dirt
that one is more sweeter oh really
oh why is the pineapple color so dark
here I like the fruits in Taiwan are
freaking we have a special guest today
at your fun who do we have here
my best friend Becky so what's up with
the the receipts in Taiwan you have to
keep them because every two months
you can win money so this right here is
the lottery the lottery oh yeah so if
you pass three and three digits you can
win $200 for I can give six hundred or a
thousand notice how one do that so it
was kind of like a an incentive for you
he follow you
so we what is the number
are you running away like a nation I
said I'm gonna steal a Becky I don't
even live here
what kind of Chinese Bing bong stuff of
that but I don't touch me
what did you think I was gonna steal it
from you here protective of my receipt
you think I was like that too don't
worry about it
so try not about the way turns Chinese
as hell
[Music]
so we just got going through old town
which is an alleyway and Joe fun where
everybody goes through to buy trinkets
souvenirs they have amazing Street food
in there this is basically Taiwanese ice
cream but as around and what's inside
it's a thin rice paper right like a thin
rice paper like a tortilla and so
there's ice cream a scoop of ice cream
there's peanuts and so on
oh so this is the one that you're
talking about the gear super exciting
over
I don't reminds me of mint when you put
it in like American desert a really
freshness and then it's like that super
sweet nutty peanut in there and that ice
pants frickin awesome
this is so awesome one of the best ones
I've had I love this the experience is
very very very unique for example we
were walking through everybody next to
us his shoulder the shoulder and it's
packed and the funny thing is that Becky
told us that that's not even the most
pack that it is it is actually pretty
okay today but there was scooters and
being passed by I'm talking about this
is an alleyway where only about two
three people maybe which wise can fit
scooter zooming by there was a point
where I was got ran over by a truck
because a truck full of equipment was
coming through and they were just kind
of pushing this all the way through but
if you guys have not been to Taiwan I do
suggest you guys come here it's a very
unique experience
it's super fun it's great for pictures
food and everything else hey guys so
this is one of the most popular places
in Joe fun is where at the top right now
and here they're known for something
called coin which is a sweet potato and
taro rice cakes so this is what it is so
they put ice on the bottom and then all
the toppings are actually really hot and
when they pour it it becomes more like a
soup but food soup and what we do is
just come over here sit down these small
little two
school and just look at the view and
enjoy and have a good time
so we have here rabbit ro green bean and
sweet potato rice day and we also have
red bean and mung bean as our another
topping it's weird when uh when a lot of
people talk about desserts in Asia
there's a lot of like unorthodox things
when it comes to like American palate
that we eat for example this is just ice
and a lot of different beans and other
types of rice cakes now rice cakes if
you guys never had that it's very chewy
and let's go
young Chui mochi awesome texture that
the other earthly Beach this kind of a
nice bird be like sweet flavor to it
so this is the famous tea house that you
guys saw is spirited away spirited away
is one of Miyazaki's most popular not
the most but one of his most popular
animated films and singing a person is
freaking amazing
so I'm super hyped of--this and this is
one of the biggest why even came to Joe
fund so I've been here twice I don't
once or twice and we actually miss I
never seen this before
I see never like stop five it was it was
so busy that we just did a huge beers
out the thing awesome I didn't know that
was here till like Reese oh he's amazing
did you know I never thought cuz you
know before we came here to Taiwan I
didn't think I didn't have any
expectation of how much I was gonna
enjoy it
and I think so far the sex is bad with
detention
[Music]